there's this sort of eternal tension
you know between um one between desiring
equality
between the sexes and acceptance and
acknowledging the difference
the physiological differences between
the sexes and i think that you know i
mean that tension is not one that you
can
abolish even though you know recent
activists are definitely trying
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
our brilliant guest today is a writer
for unheard mary harrington welcome to
trigonometry thank you for having me oh
it's great to have you on
francis and i have both reading many of
your articles recently and really
enjoying your work from a kind of
independent
thinking person's perspective which is
really really cool
uh for anyone who doesn't know who you
are tell everybody a little bit about
your background what has been your
journey through life
how do you find yourself sitting here
talking to us um well i fell into
writing
completely by accident well not
completely by accident but mostly by
accident about 18 months ago
i mean i left uni i read english
literature at university and like most
english
undergrads wanted to become a writer
when i grew up spent my 20s writing
completely unreadable garbage
and eventually came to the conclusion
that actually no i was i was going to
park that because
i didn't really have anything to say
that anybody wanted to hear and i should
probably go off and do some stuff
because i didn't really know enough
to have anything very useful to say so i
did i did a lot of stuff about 20 years
worth of stuff
in fact it started with founding
founding a web startup or nearly
founding a web startup in my 20s which
kind of
came to an end in 2008 with the great
crash
then i went off and retrained as a
psychotherapist i left london
got married had a child um
spent stint as a stay-at-home mum and
fell into writing kind of by mistake
through that
because when she got to about two i just
started you
i mean you spend the first couple of
years with the child being very
preoccupied and just kind of in love
with your child
and then when about after about two
years you start to get some of your own
sort of brain functions back
i thought you were gonna say and you
start hating them no no no no i mean the
the love never goes away of course
um nor does the mum bluetooth really but
the bluetooth gets less intense when
they get a bit older
um so i started to get some of my own
brain functions back
and i i mean i don't you know
not to put too fine a point on that i
started to get a little bit bored
um so i started blogging my daughter's
artwork in the style of contemporary art
gallery
um it was kind of a running joke really
with a friend who is actually
she's a writer on art and a digital
artist
and she who had who had a baby at the
same time as me and an old friend from
university
and we started we started sending each
other kind of you know
toddler toddler scrolls but with very
very serious chin stroke in commentary
in the style of a you know
an art gallery and i i started blogging
them just because it was
it was just something to do and it kind
of accidentally went viral
and a friend of mine you know an old
friend from my startup days
i ran into said oh mary you should write
more because
because i really enjoyed here it's
really funny i mean she's a mum and also
she was
she's a gallery owner and she just found
the whole thing hilarious you know you
should write more so so i did
i started i thought well i've got a bit
of time you know my daughter's seeing
going to a child minded for a few hours
a week i'm going to spend a bit of that
time
writing because i can and i've always
i've always enjoyed it so
why not so i pitched a couple of things
to a couple of places
and then i'd literally written two or
three
things for no money and unheard got in
touch and said would you like to pitch
to us and i said okay
and as it happens i had a pitch half
written which i hadn't dared to send to
them
so i said well would you like would you
be interested in this and they said
maybe and i so i wrote that for them and
i think i've written for them pretty
much every week since
that was september 2019
and i mean it's it's not really it's not
really a story which is
ever supposed to happen i think but
that's that's basically well i'm glad it
has happened uh mary because as i say i
think you're you're writing and
it it's very clear to me that you're
someone who's lived a life
outside of the commentary uh
that that comes very strongly through
your work i think a lot of people
uh sort of you know go to oxford go to
cambridge do this degree do that degree
and then by the time they're 25 they're
writing for the whatever and look
there's nothing wrong with that but i
think
your your commentary is informed by that
so
let me ask a question that we we always
try to ask if we can of people
as broadly as possible what is happening
in the world in your opinion
at the moment and why well i think we've
several things we've we've gone out the
other end of never-ending growth
we have left the era of never-ending
growth and most and a lot of what's
happening at the macroeconomic level is
people kicking the can down the road
with their hands over their ears and
saying la la la as loudly as possible
so that's one thing i think which is
happening we've also come out the other
end
of um we're already into the era
of ecological exhaustion and slow motion
ecological collapse
we are well and truly into the
anthropocene i mean these are all sort
of very macro things
um we've we've we've left the era of
liberal democracy
and are now living in something else and
i'm not completely sure what to call it
yet
and we've we've left the industrial age
and are now in the digital age and all
of these things are interacting in ways
which are
complicated you know infinitely
complicated and i guess my writing is
about trying to make sense of
all of the different ways everything we
believed and everything we thought was
good
in the previous age is now bad in the
new age
that's my sort of overarching thesis for
where we are everything everything that
was good is now bad
and working working through working
through how that affects people so just
to finish on that uh
well not to finish on that i don't think
we're going to finish on that anytime
soon
no no we've literally just started just
before francis jumps in because i know
he has a lot of questions for you as
well
everything was good is now bad so what
used to be good
uh family good tradition
like give us give us a little flesh on
the bones there well
i mean i would i would actually turn
that round and i would say you know
everything
all the liberating ourselves from family
used to be good
it's not bad because we've we've got
about as liberated from family as it's
possible to get with that
i mean on the the conservative think
tank onward published a report just
today
um reporting on the epidemic of
loneliness among young people
you know many of whom report just
literally having no friends though
i mean at best they just have a set of
parasocial relationships but they have
no friends
i mean i think i don't think i don't
think people need to be any more
liberated
from emotional commitments than they
already are
and yet we still have this sort of
legacy narrative about how
we should just be free to be free to be
who we want man
and i don't think that i don't think
that's interacting in a healthy way with
actually where we are that would be just
one example there are lots
mm-hmm and you said there are lots of
examples when you were started to tell
to talk to us about where we are i just
felt myself sinking into a deep
depression
harry i'm gonna be honest natural state
for him you know i'm a comedian that is
a natural state is it as depressing as
it sounds
well i mean when i say when i all of i i
give you all of these pretty kind of
miserable headliners but i mean all of
these are very
long-term slow motion things so you know
ecological collapse collapse isn't
something which is likely to happen
tomorrow
it will happen in slow motion over the
course of decades
and probably you know and it might just
look like radical climate change and a
completely different geopolitical setup
i mean it's not going to look like
complete obliteration of the human
species i don't think or like
you know sort of the matrix like rise of
the machines scenario
that all seems a bit far-fetched but you
know we i mean
weather patterns becoming unpredictable
is something which has been remarked on
a lot this year
it's not the first year that weather
patterns have seemed strange um you know
weather has has pretty
enormous downstream effects again in
slow motion
you know migrations of whole peoples you
know there are
there are arguments that that the little
ice age had colossal
geopolitical effects over the course of
um well the the beginning of the
enlightenment
um and the whole sort of late medieval
period
um you know we we might just be in for
that but you know this is all you know
this could be a narrative arc of 100
years
you know most of which you you and i
won't be alive for
so you know there's plenty of room for
beauty and endeavour and heroism and you
know all of the kind of you know
granular human stuff
in all of that right and plus soon
you'll be dead mate yeah and and we're
all going to die anyway so
so whatever you know there's plenty of
plenty of room to have have birthday
parties and kids and
you know live heroic lives good times
completely pear-shaped yeah and it might
not go pay-shaped i mean
you know we could be we could be on the
cusp of something amazing as well but i
think they're
it's it's definitely a mixed bag but you
say like we're moving from the
industrial age to the digital age to me
i very much see
covid as a catalyst for that yes would
you
delve into that a little bit more for us
how covert has essentially speeded up
everything it has
it has i mean i think there was a lot of
those trends were pretty well
established already
i mean i think the the the headliners
there
are virtualization and d and
centralization
you know centralization and
dematerialization
so there's a bit of a mouthful but
you know the the ideas there being that
for example where
local newspapers were once the sort of
you know mediators of news
you know the functions that used to be
taken by local newspapers have
just got eaten up by facebook which is
this centralized platform
that talks about disintermediating and
you know
just freeing everybody up to just do
their amateur thing
and to an extent that's true i mean you
know independent media is a marvelous
thing i'm here enjoying it and
participating in it
but but there's also but the the
smashing the the knocking away of all of
those intermediate institutions for
example in journalism
has created a space where you know
suddenly a very few players have an
enormous amount of power
so as as for example we see when um big
tech can decide on mass to de-platform
the president of the united states
which happened not so long ago so the
dematerialization so you know all of
those all of those local newspapers are
physically no longer there
you know a lot of them have just gone um
and centralization
um big tech now controls an enormous
amount of uh what's of the available
bandwidth for what is or is not sayable
and i mean that's that that's one one
instance um but but the trends are
observable in all kinds of places
i mean you can even see it in the church
of england which is kind of a bonkers
example to give
you'd think but you know there was a
there's been a hoo-ha this week
about the church of england releasing a
report where they're saying well
actually actually we don't need churches
or even priests we can just have lay
people
can you know evangelizing and growing
the church of england they can all just
meet up in people's houses and it'll be
great
and that will free up unnecessary
resources from
i don't know quite what they're planning
to to maybe they just
want to free up free up more bishop time
to produce power points or lobby the
government on
on foreign aid spending i don't know
quite quite what it is that they propose
to replace
uh ministry with but i mean but but you
see what i mean it's the same pattern
there's a sort of there's a measure of
centralization
in among a smaller group of sort of
managerial elite types
coupled with um coupled with things
dematerializing
you know this idea that you know in fact
we can do without church buildings and
it's the same it's
it's roughly the same template as the
dematerialization
and centralization of news media and
what do you think
what do you effect do you think this is
having on society well i think well one
one impact it's having is that it's it's
annihilating all the people in the
middle
um in a sense you know it's it it's just
it's obliterating the middle class
it's and you by obliterating do you
genuinely mean obliterating as in there
will be no middle class
and that is the inevitable consequences
of what we're saying i don't think it's
i don't think it's inevitable but it has
already hollowed out an enormous stretch
of the middle class
i mean if you if you consider if you
consider all of those jobs that used to
be there for example in journalism or in
manufacturing or in you know any of
these sort of physically based
occupations and industries um which are
now which are now there
which have been either been physically
outsourced to other countries
or they've been or they've been
virtualized and rendered more efficient
i mean i suppose we could take the law
for example you know which is a
classical
middle class profession um you know with
with clerical jobs increasingly
going to ais um yeah such as you know
once upon a time there was a guy whose
job it was just to go and find things in
the archive
you know but the moment you can replace
that with a search engine you know the
law firms can save themselves a lot of
money right
um and and the consequence of that is
that
you know an awful lot of people who once
had
reasonably well paid clerical jobs now
don't anymore
um so i i don't know if i mean
completely obliterating is probably
that's putting it rather strongly
you know there's still plenty of
middle-class people left um but
you know if you look at that i mean one
of the things i wrote about
not long ago was what i what what i call
a ella's law
um which is to say the internet power
law is now being rolled out in real life
and this is the the intent that you know
the power law of how things work on the
internet
um has been has been observable since
the early days of social media
the 1990 law which is to say
um on in any given social internet space
uh one percent of the users will
generate
most of the content the next nine
percent will generate quite a lot and 90
will mostly just hang out a bit um but
that also that also goes for earnings on
the internet
so if you look at if you look at any
given internet platform say ebay or
amazon or youtube indeed um
one percent of the one percent of the
contributors will reap most of the gains
um nine percent will re will do pretty
well and ninety percent will just get
the long term
um ayla has ayla posted a graph
um ayla for anybody who doesn't who
isn't aware is an extremely high earning
performer on the
pornography website only fans um she's
she's in the top 0.6
i believe of earners and in a good month
can make several hundred thousand
dollars
um so so she's she's right up at the top
of the curve but the majority of the
majority of performers are only fans
or indeed the majority of sellers on
ebay will will make you know a few quid
here and there
um and that that law i see in the
digital age i think is being rolled out
in real life as well
so and i mean one of the things you talk
about covenant lockdown
one of the things that's definitely been
happening is the further accumulation of
wealth right at the top
yep yep and the admiseration of
everybody else yes
kovid has rolled out ayla's law um
comprehensively throughout all kinds of
areas of society which were still
resisting it
because it effectively banned real life
alternatives to
this kind of virtualization and
centralization that i'm talking about
and what about uh francis did you have
another question about this
yes so the question i want to ask and
again
it's it's touching on the real world
impacts
what effect does that have on the real
world now we've talked about the middle
class
but doesn't that just exacerbate the
atomization the feeling of loneliness
because
we're destroying our communities aren't
we
great happy yeah you can't answer you
were looking
yes everything is [ __ ] congratulations
man you can relax now
let me ask something else uh uh mary we
joke of course but
seriously in terms of the the culture
coming back perhaps to where we started
you were talking about how everything
that used to be good is now bad
can we get more into that because uh
i guess this is one of the things we've
been wrestling with
on the show that there seems to be a
radical cultural transformation
and and you know if you talk to jordan
peterson he'll say that it's
it's primarily driven by technology
other people have different points of
view about it
but there's a sort of feeling like the
the pace of cultural change
is accelerating and the world
is very rapidly becoming unrecognizable
so i'll give you an example
i i was just in ukraine a few weeks ago
visiting my grandmother who's 95
and she said to me hey what do you do
for a living and b what your book about
and i found myself unable to speak
because how do you explain
these things to a 95 year old in ukraine
who lived through
stalinism and the german nazi occupation
like
she does not she's very clued up for a
95 year old but she has absolutely no
reference for all this nonsense that the
three of us are involved with
so what is happening in the culture and
why do you feel
i think that's it that's a difficult
thing to answer comprehensively because
it completely depends where you're
standing i mean as your as your
grandmother
illustrates i mean what's what's
happening
what's happening in where we are in east
london is very different to what's
happening
where i where i am in bedfordshire
where i live in bedfordshire i mean
they're they're related obviously
um but they're but they're not quite the
same thing at all so i mean where i
where i live in
bedfordshire has been up until now at
least relatively immune to a lot of this
radical stuff
you can still say pretty much what you
like to people um
if there are there are still strong
local community bonds
you know it's it can it contrasts quite
quite sharply with what life is like
say in a very high turnover part of
the the the country's capital
um most most people where i live have
have jobs locally um
but that doesn't really you know it's
not it's not so much a zoom classes
place but it but it's also
but it's also right at the sharp end of
um
a lot of the sort of economic
transformation of the country
you know where i live right on the
oxford or the oxford cambridge arc which
is where they're planning to build the
10 million or whatever it is houses that
the country is currently missing
so all of the all of the green spaces
that i currently run through and enjoy
just as footpaths and countryside will
probably be gone in the next 10 years
and turned into you know never-ending
urban sprawl i have very mixed feelings
about that because on the one hand
people have got to live somewhere
and on the other hand i i like the
countryside where i live
and enjoy and would prefer to live in
the countryside so
um what is what is happening in
the culture overall in in terms of you
know what
everything that we thought was good is
bad and everything
it it just it's not something i find
easy to
answer because it's it's so contextual
it really is
i mean below i would argue that of
course for the moment you
you can feel somewhat isolated from
what's happening in east london
in bedfordshire you can for the moment
right but you are isolated from it in
the same way that a
manufacturing worker in the 90s was
isolated from
from people who believed in
globalization in london right
you're isolated from it until it takes
your job yes
right and and you're isolated from the
culture war and whatever else until
until the the public education system
starts teaching your three-year-old
whatever
it is gender ideology or whatever else
you want
so the that i feel that anyone who
thinks that way and i'm not saying that
you do but anyone who has that illusion
is going to get disabused of it very
very quickly i think that's absolutely
true i mean i occupy a funny sort of
position in living where i do in that
most most of my working life is spent in
in in the discourse you know with a
capital t and a capital d
you know i mean the discourse is kind of
what i do for a living and i've been
i've been very online for 20 years
so i enjoy living in the countryside and
i run a lot
because that's the only way i can stay
sane and stop myself from just drifting
away all together into the discourse
um so on the one hand i enjoy being
grounded in a local community
where you know there are i have local
mum friends etc on the other
on the on the other i have this sort of
parallel existence which is in this
strange kind of disembodied world where
people worry about this stuff
and you know and it really does give me
double vision sometimes so i wonder you
know
i wander around my local area and
sometimes it just feels insubstantial
as though it could just sort of blow
away like like a sand castle drying out
and just become i don't know what will
be left behind
you say and you it's a very powerful
image that you've just used
do you think that that's what's going to
happen inevitably or do you think there
will be a push back against what we're
seeing
i mean i probably neither
i mean england's market towns have been
around for a long time you know
where i live has existed for the last
thousand years
you know i don't think that's i don't
think it's likely to disappear overnight
um but but although i don't really
believe in progress
in any sort of absolute sense i don't
think it's a thing um i do
you know cultures do evolve and you know
places
places and communities change their
meaning and their inflection over time
and there's sort of there's nothing you
can really do about that so i'm kind of
i'm sort of fairly resigned doomer
in that sense you know i don't i don't
see my i don't i don't see
bedfordshire and it's community it's
just kind of blowing away like a
sandcastle in the wind
but i do i do think i do think as you
say things are changing
very rapidly um and a lot of the things
that we we thought
were just dead certs forever are really
not
um when you say you you don't believe in
progress
what do you mean by that because i mean
objectively speaking
if we compare ourselves to humanity 100
years ago 200 years ago 500 years ago a
thousand years ago
i think you'd be very you'd be very easy
to argue humanity has made a lot of
progress
well i mean i would actually disagree i
mean
because i think at the moment if you say
well
you know we've we've progressed over the
last thousand years you've got to define
what you mean by progress
longer longer life expectancy right but
at that point you've already begged the
question
i've already begging the question as in
you've
you know in in the in the way you
phrased the question you've already
you've already predetermined your answer
uh okay so but would you would you argue
that it's unfair to say that people
living longer healthier lives
uh i mean i see what you're saying my
point is that there's always
trade-offs yeah yeah i see what you're
saying so for example you might argue
that the fact that we live longer
is a product of a society that also
means we live in atomized
groups and therefore we're not connected
with family we have fewer children
and and blah blah blah and we end up
dining care homes as opposed to being
looked after by immediate family just so
yeah just so you know what what i'm
saying is not that you know certainly
that nothing ever gets better or that
we're getting worse my point is
my you know the reason i don't believe
in progress in some sort of an absolute
sense
is that i think all the all the things
that we measure as progress are just
measured as such
by bracketing all of the ways that they
constitute trade-offs
so you know the moment you frame such
and such as as pro as
as your your met your metric for
progress you've already
you've already um answered your own
question okay what about penicillin
well i mean but penicillin is great um
but but yeah what what about superbugs
touche touche i mean you know
my my point is simply that you know it's
it's not obvious to me
that humanity you know taken in its
total
is you know in a is in some way morally
improved from
over a thousand or two thousand years
ago let me keep trying it
what about a lack of stalinism and uh
and
purges and gulags and well sure but we
didn't have stalinism before
stalin either yeah i mean we kind of did
though didn't we
like you know we had the inquisitions
and the what about
what about xinjiang then yeah you know
we we don't not have stalinism anymore
it's true you know that's true
i i don't believe in progress right well
i'm going to get depressed as well
it's great to have you on mary we
thought you know we'd get someone
interested in but
yeah just you know you know this is the
ultimate black pill episode yeah
absolutely
yeah i think the thing is like it's not
it's not that i
i'm you're not depressed about it you're
just not yeah i'm really not depressed
about any of this yeah because it's so
bad why bother
yeah do you take a certain nihilistic
glee in it absolutely
not no i i think there's there's immense
scope
in human life for beautiful heroic
wonderful transcendental experiences i
just don't think
things are necessarily never-endingly
getting better
yeah you know humanity evolves and
cultures and ideas and people
and places and every everything evolves
and
just just tracing that is itself
astonishingly beautiful
um it's just it's just not constantly
getting better it's just changing
i think i think there's a lot of truth i
mean if you look at the last
decade to suggest that things are
getting better would
i'm not sure i'd buy that argument yeah
i mean it depends where you're standing
you know i mean if you're
if you're an upper middle class white
person who
who inherited wealth sometime in the
late 1990s
and got on the london housing ladder
before the before the colossal boom
then you'd be forgiven for thinking that
things things have been continuously
getting better
but you know for somebody not very far
down the road from that person it really
might not feel like that at all or for
you know not that many years younger
than that person it might not feel like
that at all
you know if you're no it's it's it's an
excellent point
i mean let's touch on a subject that has
never upset or offended anybody who gets
anybody angry feminism
you write to love you write a lot about
feminism i particularly enjoy your
articles would you describe
yourself as a feminist mary and if you
do what does that mean to you well my
twitter bio says reactionary feminist
okay what does that mean well it's it
it started as some banter it was
literally just a running joke between me
and one of my friends i had a
long-standing argument with a friend
about the term post-liberal which people
attached to me i don't attach it to
myself
but people attached the term
post-liberal to me and i had a
long-standing argument about with a
friend who who's
of the opinion that i was not a post
liberal i was a reactionary and i said
no i am not a reactionary i
reactionaries are bad people
and he he's finally sort of you know his
take is essentially that post liberals
are just reactionaries who don't inhale
um and you know it was a it was a very
long running very sort of it was a
a long-standing banter back and forth
about about post liberals and
reactionaries
and in the course of which i changed my
twitter bio just to see how long it
would take him to notice
but i thought i came to think that
actually it's it
it's a fun placeholder i like
reactionary because people are going to
call me that anyway
they're bound to because i i acknowledge
for example that humans can't change sex
um which is already already as a serious
enough heresy to have you
have you dumped among the bad people and
also because i don't believe in progress
and one of the questions that has
preoccupied me for a long time
is how is is it even possible
to to take to argue for women's
interests if you don't believe in
progress
because feminism as we understand it is
pretty inseparable from the whole sort
of liberal progress narrative
this idea that you know we are we're
going from a bad place where everything
everything was terrible and benighted to
a good place where everybody is
enlightened and it's all good and we
have rights and
so on um why is that not true i mean you
can vote now you
you know your husband can't beat you
with a stick yes which is all great you
know
i'm i'm very much in favor of them what
are the trade-offs that you are
concerned about
well in that situation
i mean what is worth being beaten with a
stick for
i guess is what i'm getting at i mean
that's a bold question mate i'm going to
be obviously
i'm just following the logical line here
um
and giving mary the opportunity to
elucidate give give me give me a nice
long length of rope that i can hang
myself with
let me be let me be perfectly clear i am
fully fully fully
in favor of and very grateful to my
foremothers for securing
for me um the right to exist as a person
you know in contemporary post-industrial
contemporary sort of liberal era
uh terms there's a very very very long
answer to your question which we
probably don't have time for today
to do with the i mean it's essentially
my thesis that what we understand
as feminism is one iteration in the
context of industrial
modernity over much of just an eternal
debate which is to say
how men and women can reconcile their
not always perfectly aligned interests
which are fundamentally rooted in our
different reproductive roles
you know what men what men want and need
out of out of the opposite sex and out
of society is not
doesn't completely overlap with what
women need and
you know a lot of you know and it's an
eternal source of kind of cultural
negotiation let's say um how how we go
about squaring these two sets of
interests
and in different material contexts and
different you know sociocultural context
that plays out very differently
and it is my view that in the context of
uh
industrial modernity um
well when when when society is
industrialized
that left women quite disadvantaged in
some in some ways which are specific
to to the material conditions of
industrial modernity particularly to do
with how work was reorganized you know
suddenly this very stark split between
work and home which left women
um pretty very on the back foot and you
know so to an extent still subject to
an older set of patriarchal social codes
but with without any of the
social and cultural power that they had
previously wielded you know in us in a
medieval setup
in other words you're expected to go to
work and you don't have the sort of
the protections that are afforded to
women in a more patriarchal traditional
society
well you're you're getting ahead of i'm
thinking really of the 19th century here
where all of a sudden
women were women were expected to be the
angel by the half
yeah um and but they and and completely
economically and
inactive yes but then they had no they
had no
personhood independent from their
husbands as a legacy of
of an older patriarchal way of doing
things in the medieval era
which was semi i mean you know not
without problems and not without
abuses and there are plenty of you can
cite plenty of abuses of women
from the from the middle ages i mean
obviously you know which burnings
to to name but one however
you know there were it was a it was a
setup that was more or less functional
in a context where
where both both both adults in a
household worked
you know within a household i mean if
you think about you know sort of
typical kind of artisan or you know
reasonably well off
kind of yeoman household in the middle
ages you know women worked as well as
men
because everybody was engaged in in some
sort of subsistence activity
but that changed in the industrial era
because all of a sudden work happened
you know out there in a factory or
whatever
and i mean i'm talking here about the
middle classes again you know this is
it's very difficult to pin this stuff
down because it's so contextual
but for the for the bourgeoisie suddenly
women were supposed to be this kind of
this very sort of very constrained kind
of
um still no still no independent person
had still no right to own property
um and suddenly you don't really have
any role outside just raising children
and so so that that prompted you know
women who are obviously people
just like men um to say well hang on a
minute this is a bit boring
and nobody really this this is just a
bit [ __ ] so
we we we would like we would like to be
deemed persons you know under the new
well you know we we exist in a we live
in a democracy just like you can we
vote please can we own property can we
work
and you know they the but it was it was
the it was the economic shift that drove
the um that drove the political shift
and then again you know with the the
advancement of technology you know all
of a sudden
you know all of the sort of housewife
drudgery
started to fade away because you just
you don't have to do your washing by
hand anymore
and so all of a sudden that frees up a
whole lot of time and suddenly women are
looking out and thinking you know
they seem to be having a more
interesting time of it you know why
can't we go and
um you know i would quite like to work
as well you know we're just sitting
around twiddling our thumbs
i mean and this is i mean this is
immensely complicated territory and i'm
really not doing it justice
here no i actually hear a lot of what
you're saying i mean
it's even more dangerous for me to
articulate some of these identities
but i suppose uh if you look at women's
mental well-being over the last
i don't know a few decades let's say or
more than that maybe last six seven
eight decades you don't necessarily see
much progress in fact you see a decline
seemingly at least right
um so like i see your your
point about trade-offs yeah yeah yeah
i mean what we've what we've ended up in
is a situation i mean
there's this sort of uh eternal tension
you know between um one between desiring
equality
between the sexes and acceptance and
acknowledging the difference the
physiological differences between the
sexes and i think that you know i mean
that tension is not one that you can
abolish even though you know recent
activists are definitely trying
but you know it's irreducible it's how
we make new humans right
um you know unless we're going to stop
doing that um
you know there are certain irreducible
facts about how you make new humans
which are very difficult to get away
from completely and and that's
you know the fact that you know only one
sex just states and only one sex can
breastfeed
um again it's a very controversial
territory indeed
indeed we are and i'm skirting around
some really quite radioactive territory
no no indeed but i you know i'm very
careful about what i say
and on this subject no no i mean
i'm gonna get cancelled probably sooner
or later but you know perhaps perhaps it
won't be today
mary i'm going to what why why are we
so worried about skirting around this
territory when i think
you know as human you know as human
beings as intelligent adults we all know
what the troops are
why are we skirting around these
territories
well there's a
i'm not afraid of being canceled for
saying that humans can't change sex i
have no concern about that i mean i'm
out and out and proud and have been for
some time about my my views on that
so you know that's i'm not concerned
about being cancelled for that because
where that
to take place it would already have
happened however
um i i tread cautiously
when it comes to how people feel about
their identities
because i came to the subject of trans
politics via
personal involvement in the trans scene
as it
was you know very nascently in the
naughties
you know i was i i know a lot of people
who were who began
i mean all the
all the all the women i dated in the
naughties have since become men
this is something i i it's your fault
well i didn't i didn't wonder for a bit
i did wonder for a bit but i'm not
actually
yeah i mean you you joke but i did think
is it me
but no no no i really don't think it is
i think it's it's just
straightforwardly that i was you know in
as much as i'm attracted to women i was
always attracted to butch women and
not unreasonably um a lot of butch women
have opted
for life as a transgender man because
why wouldn't you
considering trans men get started get
stunning and brave and butch women get
um not not very kind or understanding
treatment i mean why would you not
um you know especially if you've been
always felt uncomfortable
with you know the expectations placed on
women and prefer to
adopt more masculine style and
presentation and dress and so on
i completely understand why why a lot of
a lot of female body
why a lot of female body people would
would offer up for that pathway
and just sort of go go all the way there
and and find and find it genuinely more
comfortable
and so you know i i i say this just to
just to explain why you know i
i'm very i i'm careful in what i say on
the subject
not because i want to skirt around the
fact that human
humans can't literally change sex but
because i think it's really important
not to dehumanize the individuals
involved who often genuinely struggle
and you know
really suffer and you know really
struggle with
you know just a sort of existential
state of discomfort
you know in in the dissonance between
their physiology and
identity and i think it's really really
important not to be dehumanizing and how
we how we talk about this because it's
very painful for a lot of people
i quite agree with you and actually i
found that comment that you made
really remarkable that there's a lot of
butch
women particularly butch lesbians who
would prefer to transition
and live their life permanently
medicalised
as a as it inverted commons as a man
than they would do
as a woman living a perfectly normal
natural life
that to me seems awful yeah
is it really that bad for them yeah i i
think being
being gender non-conforming is extremely
difficult you know
and if if anything it's more difficult
now than it was
um 20 years ago i mean i think about i
mean
my husband's a little bit older than me
he's sort of proper gen x whereas i'm
kind of
borderline borderline gen x millennial
and you know his
his musical and sort of aesthetic era is
the new romantics
i mean if you think about some of the
some some of those
some of the sort of celebrity figures
from from that era the late 80s and
up to the early 1990s they were all
gender bending merrily left right and
center
you think about marilyn and well i mean
you name you name it any of the boy
george
right exactly i mean the whole the whole
of pop culture there was filled with
people who were just really playing very
creatively
with the boundaries of gender
presentation and that all just seems to
have gone
i mean i was but if you watch top of the
pops from from that era
and you know from from the 70s through
to
through to i suppose perhaps the late
1980s i mean you think
you watch that and you see the women
form you think my god they're wearing a
lot of clothes
yeah but it's but it's really striking
and it's not just
it's not just a decency thing you know
patti smith would get up on stage
wearing a pair of sort of brown corduroy
flares
and nobody tried to put her in a little
[ __ ] britney spears sort of warrior
battle bikini like they like they do a
little
i mean you know exactly the sort of
outfit i'm talking about rhinestones
spangled battle bikinis seems to be kind
of the order of the day if you want to
be a
female performer the only way you can be
at all you know
anything curvier than anorexic is if
you're if you started life as a stripper
and you know those are those are the
options available you know the the
sec the pornification of
women in in the culture now and the
you know the sort of extremeness and the
i mean you think about the contestants
on love island
you know the all the girls are kind of
you know with their boobs hitched up to
here and their buttocks and their
fillers and the highlights and what have
you
and all the guys are there's a sort of
pumped up
pumped up kind of uh ken dolls covered
in with their arms covered in biro
you know it's this sort of incredibly
kind of cartoonish you know hyper
masculine and hyper feminine
stereotypical um aesthetic
which which yeah
it doesn't leave doesn't leave very much
scope for
gender creative expression so i can i
can really understand
how people who just don't comfortably
fit those sorts of extreme stereotypes
could
could find themselves thinking well
actually maybe i should just join the
other team
and just literally become the other team
because that's just going to be less
less of a miserable paradox to try and
occupy
i get that and i can see why people
would think no actually the
uh the trade-offs in terms of you know
osteoporosis and
you know 25 years off my life or
whatever it whatever it is
you know it's that seems
that seems like a reasonable trade i can
see how people get there
that that is so sad when you consider
what the narrative that is being fed to
us that you know we're more free liberal
than ever before
we're more accepting than ever before
but actually
you know the narrative that the media is
showing us the images and also let's be
fair social media as well
it's it's very much the opposite of that
isn't it yeah i mean one of the
i i did a i wrote something about um
how i i wanted to i wanted to explore
you know the what what's understood
about you know
how much you know what what basis is
there for thinking about you know
they're actually you know psychological
normative differences between the sexes
i looked into it and i found a really
interesting study
um which showed that um
[Music]
the people are more likely to think of
themselves as very masculine or very
feminine
in societies where where the material
where materially people are more
egalitarian
so people cling more strongly to
masculine and feminine sex roles
the more egalitarian life is in in
reality
you know women are less likely to to go
off and study science and engineering
and maths
in where the culture is women are women
are more likely to do
um again to study egalitarian subjects
or to take an interest in science
where the culture itself is more sexist
and more sexual differentiated
which seems really odd until you think
about it
and you think well you know people
people intuitively sense
that there is you know there is
something different between men and
women we're not quite sure what it is
but you know if if everyone's saying oh
you know men and women can both do
everything and you know
men men can be stay-at-home parents and
women can be you know
you know ball busting ceos and yadda
yadda and there are in fact no material
differences between us at all
then but but people still feel
instinctively that there is something
there is something different and so
instead they kind of construct this sort
of exaggerated
masculinity or femininity as a way of
making up for the sort of
the sense that we're all just kind of
disintegrating into a sort of grey goo
i mean i mean that's that's my that's my
reading of what's going on there whether
it's whether it's true or not i don't
know
but but but my sense is that people
people want
there to be a difference of some kind
between men and women people people kind
of people feel it matters
do you think it's that they want or do
you think that they're tired of being
told there isn't even though
all their objective life experience is
telling them that there is
and they're just tired of living a lie
like with so many other issues
it could just be it could be that it
could be that i mean
i i don't know um i mean so certainly
what
what has what has felt very true to me
is that it's very you can pretend that
there are no differences between men and
women
until you have children and the fact
that more people are putting off
children until ever
later and later or just not having
children at all um
is is increasing the constituency of
people who pretend that there are no
differences between the sexes
um but but the rubber really hits the
road when you have children
um because at the end of the day you
know it's it's
um it it's only me it's
it was only me who was able to nurse a
baby you know it was me it was me who
who grew her in my literal entrails
and and actually you know
physiologically that came with a whole
load of changes i'm reading this amazing
book at the moment
that's just about this it's coming out
shortly called mum genes
which is all about the physiological
changes that come with
changing from being a woman to being a
mother because it literally
it literally rewires your brain i mean
i'm still kind of
hopefully mostly sort of functional
cognitively i think i do okay um but but
it completely rewires your brain
you know and and actually you know even
every child that you carry as a woman as
a mother
um leaves traces of their dna inside
your body permanently
and there's absolutely wild i didn't
know this um you know my sense that this
sense i had of being kind of
symbiotically connected to my baby
actually has a material basis
in the sense that you know every child
you carry you leaves traces of dna that
just sloshes around inside you
and will will actually will actually
repair injuries that you have so if you
if you cut yourself
you know the the i think that they call
it microchimerism which is to say
you know sort of genetic you you you
become sort of chimerically
interconnected with your child literally
at a cellular level
and you know the the the cell the trace
cells the trace dna which is left behind
by your child will
will repair injuries to your body you
know my i have a c-section scar that was
probably repaired by my daughter's dna
even though she was she was physically
gone from my body by then
this is just nuts when you think about
it and within this sort of atomized
paradigm we have of you know what humans
are and how humans
uh relate to one another it makes no
sense it just doesn't compute this idea
that we're interconnected and can be
interconnected
you know even at a cellular level and
that's particularly true for women
in a way which is just it can't be true
for men
you know that that's that's sort of in
violation of
a number of pretty kind of fundamental
beliefs that we have
about well for one thing about the the
sameness between men and women
and and also about the the fact that
we're all separate
and atomized and sort of propelling
ourselves around like like
like billiard balls around a table and
in fact the reality is is much messier
and stickier and more sort of
interconnected than that and that's
that's more pronounced for women than it
is for men
it's it's a really great point and it's
fascinating and one of the things that
you touched on that i particularly
wanted to talk to you about because it
was something that concerned me
when i was a teacher is what you talked
about which was the pornification of
women
what impact do you think uh pornography
is having on our society
and particularly on its impact on women
well i mean i'm not really at the coal
face of this because i've been married
for nearly ten years um i'm so i'm not
i'm not really at the sharp end of
dating and relationships so much um
but from younger friends um of both
sexes actually
my my sense is that it's it's having a
very radical impact
um women i think there have been
numerous studies done of this that
indicate
that women in particular are
experiencing much higher levels of
sexual violence violence during sex i
mean there was a study done last year
that showed that over that something
like three quarters of men
have slapped or choked or spat on um
a woman that their partner during sex
men under 40. three-quarters of them
now it may well be that some of those
women were really into it but all of
them
i doubt it i very much doubt it and this
is coming directly from pornography
and and the difficulty there is that
point i think of pornography you know
it's not a it's not a
it's it's a it has direction as well as
force
right um but by by which i mean you know
you what you watch something
that you you watch two people just
having a shag right and that's that's
really exciting and maybe
but then you watched a couple of times
and it's just not so exciting anymore so
you go looking for something a bit more
intense
and that and that that takes you
that takes any regular prolific consumer
of pornography
inexorably towards the really dark the
really violent the really exploitative
and then all the way out there beyond
the pale into i don't know children on
animals and
what have you you know pornography has
has it has force and it also has
direction
and and it also replaces
intimacy and i think this is this is a
problem that a lot of
as as i understand it a lot of young men
are struggling with some of them
increasingly consciously
i think there are there are hundreds of
thousands of members now of the nofap
boards you know where you know you
usually usually adolescent but you know
men from all walks of life are really
struggling
with pornography addiction you know
compulsive masturbation
um and i think you know people laugh and
go ah losers you know you can't keep it
in your pants but i i don't think i
don't think
i really don't think it's something to
laugh at i think what they're doing is
genuinely heroic because the
the porn industry the online porn
industry is is the most
the most kind of nakedly nakedly venal
and just completely on
out there in the open um version of the
the whole
of the the internet dopamine machine you
know
full stop you know this whole you know
that wants to commodify people's desires
um and turn them into profit centers i
mean
most of the internet is about that right
you know whether it's
you know whether it's wanting to you
know
hack the hack the desire for you know
social
applause by encouraging us to get really
addicted to social media platforms and
the likes and the retweets and what have
you
and i fully confess i have i have a
fairly fairly
serious and chronic twitter addiction so
you know i'm speaking from experience
there
we've got no idea what you're talking
about absolutely absolutely not
of course i mean you know i mean we're
all we're all um
we'll all perhaps be in recovery
together one day um right the i mean
this is this is the water we all swim in
right but the
the pornography industry takes that
absolutely to its its most squalid and
venal conclusion
you know because it's every every every
hit you get there
um it's not just a little dopamine hit
like you get from a
from a from a like or a retweet um it's
an orgasm
so you know the the rewiring is more is
is is more direct and it's more
it's more uh comprehensive and i think
for a lot of people it's it's
very very very addictive and and the
whole the whole pornography industry is
just set up directly to hack
um to to hack people's
people's you know absolutely basic sort
of lizard brain
um mechanisms for reproduction
um and the fact that there are
there's this growing subculture of young
men out there who are saying no actually
i'm going to i'm going to
disentangle the the vampire squid from
my brain i think that's genuinely heroic
and there's something really really
quite quite sort of you know radical
and yeah it's genuinely heroic and
you i don't i don't spend a huge amount
of time on the nofap boards but i've
i've i've scooted through them once or
twice um
you know not not sort of voyeuristically
but just out of curiosity to see what
the discourse there is like and it's you
know a lot of people are really
suffering
you know and they talk about falling off
the wagon and they support each other
trying to get back on it and i mean
there are there are corners of that
discourse which are a bit weird you know
the whole kind of semen retention thing
is kind of
a bit mad but and there are bits of it
get quite misogynistic perhaps as well
um but but these are people who are
trying to unplug themselves from the
dopamine machine
and that's that's almost impossible to
do you know as witnessed by my own
twitter addiction when i think about
trying to quit
twitter i just think how am i going to
do that
you know it's it's it's every bit as
addictive as the smoking
as which i which i finally quit 10 years
ago
and in some ways i think it's a direct
replacement for it
but you know these this this is the this
is where this is where we are as a
culture
yes it's interesting we're rapidly
running out of time because i think
we're trying to scratch the surface of
so much that we could talk about but
before we get to the end
uh we we brought up feminism never
really got into it
but this is an interesting perhaps point
on which to wrap that conversation up
for now until we we get you back and
talk for seven hours instead of one
uh which is what do you make then of
strands of feminism who seem to be
totally okay with this totally okay with
sex work totally okay with pornography
uh totally okay with the erosion of
women's spaces in some cases
how does that work i don't think it does
well i don't either but i'm guessing
what i'm trying to say is how has that
happened how has it happened well i'm
this is i suppose central central to my
reactionary feminist thesis is that
we've come to the end of the games that
we can be
can be made for women by centering
freedom
and you know those strands of feminism
which are now you know all about
applauding
prostitution and um
transgenderism and yada yada you know
the whole sort of meat lego
matrix this idea that we can just sort
of monetize and commodify
our bodies and that constitutes
empowerment i think that that's a that's
a set of people who are still committed
to the idea that it's possible to square
feminism with uh liberation in the
digital age and i i just disagree with
that
i think i think they're looking at it
wrong and when we need we we need to
we need a root and branch re-examination
of the material conditions we're in now
not rather than just fighting
yesterday's battles i mean if you if you
look at the digital age you know
within if you're stuck in the if you're
stuck in the industrial paradigm and you
still think more liberation is
self-evidently better
then i can see how you could end up in
that you know arguing for
sex work or arguing for um you know
uploading our consciousnesses to the
cloud or you know abolishing
um liberating women even from the from
the constraints of biological sex for
i don't know extra uterine gestation or
just being men or whatever
um yeah i can see how if you if you're
still chasing the high of liberation you
could still imagine those things might
be feminist but
i'm not chasing the high of liberation i
think we're all of us men and women
are like liberated enough and what we
need is more and better obligations
like what well i i think we need that
depends on who you are and who you're
committed to and who your obligations
are to
i mean in my case it's straightforwardly
my obligations to my family particularly
to my daughter
but also to my extended family and to
the people who i'm actually connected to
and whom i love in real life
and you know beyond that to to my
working
my working relationships and my friends
i mean there were i mean grounded
commitments in actual relationships
um you know parasocial relationships are
great and fun and interesting and
exciting
but they but they're instantial when it
comes down to it you know internet
friends come and go some of them turn
into real-life friends
you know i've been online long enough to
have to have in real life friends
who started out just as you know a dm
chat um but that's but
but but it's i think it's important to
develop an ability to discern the
difference
and to be to be able to think very
pragmatically about what actually
matters
um so you know there isn't a universal
answer what more and more and better
obligations means
but it's it's grounded in real
relationships and not in not an ideology
mary i've absolutely loved this
interview it's uh it's
it's been challenging it's we've
discussed a variety of challenges
uh slightly which for him is a dopamine
yeah yeah that is my pornography so
thank you
but uh before we do our questions for
our local supporters
uh we always have one final question
which is what is a one thing we're not
talking about
but we really should be in my opinion
it's the the the
very obvious conflict between liberal
feminism and
uh climate change ecological collapse
um in i agree with phyllis schlafly and
i'll
this may well be the point where i get
cancelled um for quoting phyllis
schlafly who's a
an american conservative of the who who
died about three months before donald
trump was elected
um but it was it was her opinion that
women's liberation was not a result of
moral progress but a modern technology
and although there are plenty that i
disagree with phyllis schlafly and i do
agree with her about that
i think a great deal of what we think of
as liberation through progress is in
fact liberation
from drudgery through machines that just
do the jobs for us
and i i hope it's i hope it doesn't
happen in our lifetimes but i can
envisage a future in which most of those
technological
gifts are no longer with us or no longer
widely available
um whether we're talking about washing
machines or whether we're talking about
um contraception um i think without
though there is a huge amount of a huge
amount of the ways in which women are
liberated now are effects of
uh of advanced of an advanced
technological civilization and should
that civilization collapse
which we should all which we must all
hope it doesn't um
we we may we might find ourselves in a
situation where actually the the
underlying underlying conditions that
enable feminism are just gone
and i think the environmental movement
in particular
is yet to get its head around that with
possible exception of roger hallam at
that extinction rebellion who's who's
considerably more switched on about this
stuff than
most of his supporters really former
guest on the show
good good good um yeah he's he's he he
gets
he gets a lot more than i think than he
lets on um but i mean just just to take
one one specific example
um hormonal contraception is
ecologically catastrophic
and this is just something this is an
elephant in the room as far as you know
i mean most environmentalists would also
consider themselves to be feminists
um so all of them all of them are keen
that you know women should have
reproductive autonomy as am i
i should say but um where when that
comes to the mass roll out of the
contraceptive pill worldwide
um we should probably bear in mind the
fact that it's having disastrous effects
on aquatic life
um it's turning literally to it it
yeah it's having disastrous effects
turning the frogs gay
well i mean that it's true so it's
turning the frog's guy you know
you know i have i have no kind of i have
no moral view on that but you know it's
obviously a problem as far as
frogs have frogs making you're not
homophobic against frogs no no i'm not
i'm not frog homophobic but you know
it's obviously a problem when it comes
to frogs making more frogs
yeah um so that i mean these are these
are probably things
that we should that we should engage
with but this is this is a conflict
which i think is just
um people are just not willing to engage
with at the moment they're like well
hopefully it's all gonna be fine so
let's just not talk about that
well what uh what a note to end the
interview on thank you very much for
coming on the show mary
if people want to find you online
ironically where is the best place to do
that
my sub stack is reactionary feminist um
and i tweet at moving circles
fabulous fantastic and make sure also to
check out mary's work
on unheard which is absolutely brilliant
mary thank you for coming thank you for
having me
it's been a real pleasure and thank you
for watching at home or listening i
thank you for being here we will see you
very soon with another
brilliant interview like this one or a
raw show all of them go out at 7 pm uk
time
or 2 p.m eastern standard time at the
same time
it is the same time but for our american
guests
guys thank you so much and we'll see you
soon
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below